we made a deal to each other that first
day
that no matter what happened we wouldn't
eat each other
because Robin of course was not a family
member
and we assured him that we would die
together
he thought you might eat him he thought
we might eat him
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
extraordinary lives the podcast from
that Bible I'm joined today by Douglas
Robertson Douglas could you give a brief
introduction to yourself
yeah well my name's Douglas Robertson
and I was cast adrift in the Pacific for
38 days
I'm aware of your story it's an amazing
one and I'm excited to hear all about it
I suppose the first thing we'll do is
give a little bit of context of who you
were before this happened what was your
life like at this point and what what
age were you and and which family
members were you with when you decided
to plan this trip
yeah well we were farmers
from the middle of England and
Staffordshire
and we were hill farmers basically it's
a very
hard way to make a living
in the penins and
I don't think the farm was particularly
successful I was the eldest son
and um
they I think my dad was at his uh end of
his tear that economically and he was a
sea captain former sea captain
and my mum was a nurse in Hong Kong they
worked both worked in Hong Kong and they
came back to England
and
being eminently qualified in other areas
decided to take up farming which they
had no qualifications for at all you
know interesting choice yes interesting
choice you know
Robin Knox Johnson
had just won the round the world race
okay and it reciting around the world in
those days was a very adventurous thing
to do because navigation was almost
extant uh compasses were all magnetic
compasses and uh see going life was
primitive so to do it in a small yacht
relying on sale alone there were there
were a few well-known names of the time
Sir Francis justice system Alec Rose and
they'd done circumnavigations but sir
Robin Knox Johnson was
um a master Mariner like my dad so my
dad had qualified as a sea captain and
Romney Knox Johnson was the same he'd
won this race and my brother Neil said
dad
if Robin Knox Johnson can sail around
the world why can't we sail around the
world in fact his exact words were
Daddy's a sailor why don't we sail
around the world
now you know kids can be responsible for
some very devastating uh outcomes you
know they that got Google thinking
dougal's your father Google's my dad
yeah he he made this decision to sell
the farm
and buy a boat and sail around the world
but just just just to go into that a bit
it you said that the farm you were the
the financially it was struggling it was
struggling yeah very sort of like closed
off rural upbringing yeah and that feels
a bit you know what was the plan after
that if you'd sold the farm and I don't
know and how long would it was a
proposed trip around the world to take
well you know you pick a number out
there don't you but four years was
picked out of there wow yeah so we we
thought we would give up four years to
do this trip I thought it's that's what
we decided wow and that's what we wanted
to as kids we wanted that so when you
say as kids can you just give me a
snapshot of the family who was planning
to go on this trip well first of all
there was my mum and dad who both come
from my dad was a former seek Captain so
he comes from a sailing background they
lived in Hong Kong so they went yachting
a lot sailing a yacht a lot there so my
mum was a nurse there and so she'd been
sailing and they'd met sailing they met
when they were actually sailing at a
yacht club in Aberdeen Harbor in Hong
Kong
uh that there was my elder sister she
was um let's get the ages right 18. okay
just finished her a levels and what was
her name Anne Ann Anne okay and she was
uh then there was me uh this eldest son
so I just finished my own levels Neil
and Sandy were twins that that they um
they were aged uh 11 12. and they just
finished their 11 plus so they were the
youngsters and maybe a bit more
idealistic than than the rest of us
because they could say things without
consequences yes at 11 years old at 11
years old my daddy's a sailor why don't
we sell around the world nobody ever
thought that Google was actually going
to consider it for a minute or two you
know and then suddenly he said why not
we'd all reach significant milestones in
our education so therefore we could take
some time off to sail around the world
but of course it was Google who really
wanted to sail around the world because
when when I looked back at it he was
escaping he was escaping the uh
Financial outcome of the farm it hadn't
worked how do you actually go about
choosing a boat or buying a boat that's
a good question
um
they that we didn't have a lot of money
so it was getting a big yacht was out of
the question but we did have a farm the
farm we sold for 8 250 pounds wow but
to be fair yacht we only paid 2 000
pounds for the lucette
because prices were much lower and one
day A letter came through from a broker
in Malta
so my dad then my sister
caught a plane to Malta I don't know why
they did this right and they they looked
at the boat and bought it there and then
there and then
but the wind
in that winter the wind was blowing from
the south for um about two months
and of course you can't film I said land
is is locked locked out from the sea for
sailing boats when the winds coming from
the south SO waiting waiting waiting
wait will this win never change
and then Christmas came and went
and then
um the wind suddenly shifted
at the towards the end 20th 21st of
January this that of 71. the the wind
suddenly shifted to the north
coming out of the north but it was gale
force but Dougal was not to be put off
and he said this is our chance if it's
now or never okay because we can't
afford to keep staying here chewing up
money you know um we've got to go so
what was the kind of from him going it's
time to go to you leaving what was the
time period in that day that's the same
day so at that point was there a sense
of trepidation that you were like oh we
were actually we were babes to the
Tigers you know we had no idea what we
were but were you excited or were you
nervous no I was scared so are we okay
sir now now suddenly oh yeah great yeah
yeah sail down the bay don't you no slap
water turn around the Headland bang big
wave hits you and then suddenly you
realize hang on it's not like this there
yeah yeah well this is what it's like
now and it's going to get worse because
this is going to go up to a full Gale
and Google said this is my training this
was the sum of my training Douglas come
here
you have to attend Google we called him
Captain Bligh behind his back because he
was a very tough character and uh he
said you see that line on the compass
that's called the lumber line I mean he
had four months to tell me that well you
had to tell me that now I don't know he
says you keep that Lumber line next to
that number
okay
yes Dad okay and I took the wheel of the
Lucid for the first time
and I held it tacked like this I thought
if you hold it tight the boat go in that
direction it's a bit like you know if
you're steering in the car you just hold
the wheel straight and you you'll go in
a straight line because we know that's
not true and of course I'm hardly onto
the wheel and the first thing it does is
jab that means the wind comes behind it
knocks the Mainsail across to the other
side like a like a bullet like a rifle
crack and the boat and and he says what
are you doing
I don't know what I'm doing Google
actually I've got no idea what I'm doing
you know and and and so that was we
learn we learn how to sail you know and
I learned that's about how I learned how
to sail the the outer sail a boat anyway
uh that night my mum said Google
can we send up the Rockets
this is that without enough you know oh
well
the flares can we send up the flares
and doogle in one of his famous uh faux
pas statements said don't be silly Linda
only a fool would be out in weather like
this
and my mum said to him exactly yeah that
was that was what we were doing you know
we were out in this heavy weather and we
were completely untrained and uh we were
having a nightmare so we we sailed down
through the bayabisca yeah in very very
heavy weather and
um we learned we learned I'll tell you
what a wave I was on watch
everybody was seasick the bilge pump
didn't work properly we had to bail the
the the the the what has happened
there's a a box of nails had fallen into
the bilges oh no and punctured the bilge
pump their Bellows on the bilge pump so
we had to bail the boat out back what
does the village pump do so it keeps the
bottom dry right wooden boats work in
the Seaway and they let water in it's
designed like that yeah and that swells
the wood up and compresses the corking
and makes it watertight but like the
working of the boat let's water sweet
gets water in so we had to bail It Out
by hand there was um uh it was Mayhem
down below it was Mayhem there the boat
was rolling so heavily and we were on
unaccustomed to it all of us we were not
used to that sort of thing and we were
in very heavy weather and I remember a
wave coming over the stair and hitting
me straight in the back
and knocked me forward onto the onto the
hatch and I lay there on the hatch and I
thought you know what I could just let
the next wave just take me over I don't
care anymore I've had enough of this we
were so seasick it was that bad yeah it
was really bad and and my mother shouted
at me she says Douglas get it she said
get inside us I'll get your father to
give you a good hiding she said and I
thought so what nothing could be worse
than this you know you you and uh you
know and and another another sort of
event was man we had this chicken
supreme we couldn't eat anything but we
had this chicken supreme and my mum made
some and she tied herself to the galley
to to make it and somebody had said to
us about instead of having dishes which
were difficult to help if you had babies
potties oh like you could hold on to
that like and it was deep they were deep
and you could put your food in there and
it wouldn't get blood because the wind
blows your food out of the dishes okay
you know if you walk on Deck with a cup
of coffee it'll blow all the coffee out
of the cup so you you have to have a bit
of deep you know uh containers so my mum
had cooked this chicken supreme which
looks pretty awful you know and you've
got to bear in mind everybody's being
seasick and then she walks aft and hands
it to Dougal to eat and Google takes the
party off and looks at it throws it over
the side and passes it back to it you
know
obviously he didn't think it was food
you know and they laughed that was the
first time we'd left for uh about 10
days right you know it would have a
baptism of Fire and we decided when we
got to Lisbon that was it
we're still we're sail the boat back
home sell it and that was the end yeah
Dad agreed had enough we'd had enough
yeah and your dad was on board no I
don't think so okay I don't think we
consulted him right I think this was
going to be a mutiny right right so
um and uh
but the sun came out
and suddenly we were in a Portugal and
this is what this was all about wasn't
it you know
and then
the Canary Islands later the South
and Promises of fine weather
and we thought the mutineers group
thought
well we'll just go to the Canary Islands
and see if it's any better but if it's
no if it's the same then we're
definitely coming back because we were
lured into it weren't we there was no
way we were going to come back from
uh a trip the trip from Lisbon to the
Canary Islands was beautiful blue Seas
fine sailing weather uh you know
Dolphins
swordfish playing in the water around us
there was no going back so it was in
that leg that we finally decided that we
were going to sail around the world and
uh we didn't have any money though so we
would have to uh work we knew that
so you'd stop in places and work we
decided we'd stop in places and work
okay and where we could where we could
so obviously not on the out Islands but
in the industrial cities we could get
work
so that was another decision we made you
can't do that today but in the back in
those days even though they had work
visas and tourist visas no they didn't
have a way of checking up so we we were
able to work sort of below the uh what
kind of jobs well I I used to gardening
and I used to do yacht deliveries a very
strong fit sailor by the time we got to
Miami I was I knew the business inside
out you know and um in fact our sales
for Baxter still he was a world famous
yachtsman delivering Yachts for him and
then I got a job as a deck boy and a
sailing ship and you know things like
that but my first job was gardening and
because I was farmer I was you know I
could do gardening weeding very easily
painting that sort of stuff and in the
black economy you joined the black
economy of different places we went to I
believe that you're
your sister ended up staying somewhere
along the way didn't she we we sailed we
sailed with the Bony and and hooked up
in different um airports of call yeah
fantastic I mean something you can dream
about well look at where Canary Islands
across the Atlantic oh up through the
Caribbean the leeward islands and the
windward Islands ended up in
in the Bahamas and it's going great and
it's going great and this is this is
more like the tropical sort of paradise
that we expecting rather than those
rough seas in the Bay of Biscay and you
know uh and we'd um we'd sailed across
the Atlantic 33 days it took us across
the Atlantic because the the trade winds
were off season
and that that is exactly the same amount
of time it took Christopher Columbus to
sail across the Atlantic 300 years
before you know what I mean so we were
sort of we hadn't sort of progressed
very far you know but we had a great
time
and the other significant event through
the Caribbean was that
a fisherman was um
Kester drift with his engines are broken
down in the Bahamas
only Dougal would do this
we were a Sailing Boat and we'd rescued
him and we took him in tow and towed him
under sail we were under sail we towed
this fishing boat into Nestle in the
Bahamas
and we made it in the papers you know
it's our 15 minutes of fame you know
this English family had saved this
fisherman and rescued toady's boat under
sail International
and and why is that towing under sail
why is that well it's just unheard of
right you too with the tug don't you
with an engine yeah you know you don't
tow something with a sailing yacht sure
yeah because sailing Yachts have to sail
to the wind you know and and but he Fred
just followed us I mean he was attached
by a rope it was a good deed my dad had
done and the local Rotary Club in Nassau
uh
uh wanted us to um they wanted to reward
us for helping one of their citizens out
and one of the rotarians had a dive
sharpen
he he said you guys just come take
anything you want wow you can just have
anything you want out of out of here
because you know you should and we went
on dive trips with them but this chap
had a son
and this son and my sister
fell in love with each other
that's happens
and and suddenly announced that she was
no longer
going to come on the trip she was
leaving wow that sounds fast
how long did that take them to fall in
love it was pretty instantaneous
I mean you know talk about people good
looking guy from a wealthy family yeah
but he was already promised oh you came
from a super wealthy family
and uh that they uh the parents were not
uh very pleased that he'd fallen in love
with her he was promised to the heir of
the Revlon family okay and he was not to
fraternize with uh you know low life
Yachts people
but Jeff
stood up to his mother and said no we're
going to get married
and suddenly what it went from visit you
know tearing Fred in to this uh into the
uh Harbor at Nassau and Anne saying that
she was going to get married how old was
she how old was Anna 18.
okay and Jeff was how old age 21 wow
yeah and my mother was Furious of course
and Diego was Furious and it was that
and but they were insisted on it
and it was a sad day when Anne left us
and she stayed and she stayed in Nassau
yeah so you set off again but so we
without Anne unbelievably bear in mind
no telephones the only means of
communication was air male letters right
and Dougal and Linda decided that was
okay
and they were going to leave their
daughter in Nassau
so we went to Miami for six months we
all got work made money and then there
were only five of us
and how how long you've been going now
in total after after Miami I must have
been we were six months in Miami yeah so
working yeah and uh so in total so we
must have been a year then I can
actually work it out if you count the
sailing date as January 71 it was now
January 72. right okay so after
Christmas just after Christmas and again
Dougal did his famous we're leaving
today okay but you know what we could
have all settled in Miami we loved
America we we you know I mean it was it
was burgeoning out there was no
skyscrapers in America right but I mean
now it's covered in skyscrapers the
economy was booming it was like sort of
uh it was just finally free from the
depression of War you know in the the
war and you know Kennedy getting shot
and they'd landed some money on the moon
and everybody was very upbeat in America
we sailed for another six months we went
to Fantastic places uh and we sailed
South through Jamaica great place
Jamaica was in a very rough very
dangerous but a great nice on down
through the San Blas Islands which were
fantastic matriarchal society of a lost
Like A Lost Civilization
uh through the Panama Canal
and out in the Pacific Ocean
and we went then onto the Galapagos
Islands and we cruised the galapis
islands for three weeks
and um we we had met
we we took a passenger from Jamaica to
San Blas because samblast is very
difficult to get to okay he paid Scott
his name was Scott Tritt he's a helped
finance The Voyage again
and then we met Robin Williams but Robin
who's part of this story not okay so
just for anyone listening not aware of
it not the Robin Williams yes the the
robin one well yes from this story yes
yes no no not him no no this was our
Robin yes yeah okay and who was Robin
Williams he was a passenger who was
hitchhiking around the world hitchhiking
hitchhiking I mean they did in those
days so hitchhiked on boats hitchhiked
on boats and uh yeah is he British
British yeah public school okay well
spoken my dad thought at last I can
fulfill my promise to educate the
children while they're at Sea because
this guy was brewing with facts and
figures okay you know how old was he he
was 23. oh young guy yeah young but
older older than me yes about a couple
of years you know three through maybe
four years but three or four years
and um they uh
so he joined the ship and joined the
yacht in Cologne Panama
fell through the canal
to Panama City and from Panama City out
to Galapagos Islands took us 10 days
to uh to sail that trip
and although we didn't realize it then a
significant event took place
and that was a very large whale 50-foot
well
tried to make love to the boat rolled
over and rubbed its belly up against the
boat okay
and um you know that that
um
plume of water that comes out yes you
know it stinks like you would not
believe it's like putrid concentrated
brussels sprouts
and it just made the whole boat in this
foul's Mount that clung for a couple of
days
obviously that whale thought we were
another whale yeah and um had made a
mistake
and
um it didn't occur to any of us at that
moment that maybe we looked like a whale
from underneath the water
and had been a sort of case of mistaken
identity the whale realized that there
was nothing cooking and swam off and
left us
and um
we we got to the Galapagos Islands about
a week after that
and as I say we cruised the garbage
Sands fantastic fantastic place no water
no water on the club of sand
and so we'd had to take on extra water
to
um make it all the way across to the
Marquesas which is where we were going
so it's a 2 700 mile trip
and um you know we were going to be at
sea for after once we left Galapagos we
were going to be at sea for a 45 days
maybe that sort of time we'd geared
ourselves up for that sort of time span
we did carry buckets of survival
equipment ready for should we need them
but on this occasion because the water
situation in Galapagos
we had emptied them and filled those
buckets with water
and that was a very unfortunate
thing to have done
so
we were we we
finished our trip by walking up the
volcano and mount fernandino
and I we one last trip to um
Isabella Ireland
and I wrote the yacht's name on the
cliff in paint painted it along with
some very famous names written on there
and um we then set sail
Robin was having still learning how to
sail and he was not a sailor
and um
we were two days we'd sell 200 miles in
two days it was rough it was quite rough
it was in a reach so we Rift it would
Rift the sails down
and um everything was going okay
and um
then
and
June the 15th was the date
it was 10 o'clock in the morning just 72
still 72 yeah yeah
and um
I'd I'd been on the late the midnight
watch and um
I'd come up on deck at about must be
quarter to ten
and um
my brother Sandy was on on the wheel
steering the boat
and
we both saw something over on the
starboard bow now when you're a mariner
of years experience as we were by then
seasoned I mean far from the Falmouth
days we were seasoned Sailors who knew a
lot about sailing yachts and how heavy
weather and
could be calmed and sailed stitching
sales and rigging and you know we we'd
lived on this boat yeah for two years
now nearly almost and
but we saw this dark black
thing Pats uh
shape in the Seaway
and we knew it wasn't a bird because
birds have got a softer profile it was
like a hard profile
and now know that it was the fin of a
killer whale um
but we were still not perturbed by that
and um
the um the fishing line was dancing
and I pulled it in and there was a squid
on the end of it and I remember saying
to Sandy
I swear the squid there's usually bigger
fish because they eat squid a lot of
sperm whales and things like that he I
just said bigger fish
and the next second
um bang bang
like a like a a bullet like a shot from
a Howitzer like a big gun
the the crack was so loud that it hurt
our ears and I believe that was probably
the Keel breaking snapping in half
and the boat was Jarred in the in the
Seaway and lifted bodily up from from
the water so that it should have jolted
it off our feet
and you know nobody knew what that what
had happened
and I remember
pumping my head down
the hatch to look at my dad
and um he was up to his ankles in water
oh no and and I said Google what are you
doing
because I hadn't put two and two
together yet and then there was a loud
splashing surfing noise behind us and I
turned my head and there were three
killer whales
following us
I'd like if you like a daddy a baby and
a mummy if you like a big daddy at this
side closest to us his head was split
open
and a water a blood was pouring into the
sea
and I remember thinking whales don't to
animals don't hurt themselves
on purpose you know they must have
attacked us and uh you know my mind went
back to that whale at tried to make love
to the boat and now it looks like we've
been mistaken for a while again
and uh but but this time with dire
consequences I put poked my head back
down the hatch I said the whale's dad
and but he was up to his waist in water
now wow so and he said abandon ship
now of course I was 18 and knew
everything and Google was in 47 and knew
nothing see so I said to him Dougal
where do you think we're going to
abandon ship to
I said this is not Miami Marina
and Google said
over there
get the life raft launched and I thought
he's bloody serious you know
I thought now now I must be dreaming
this is not happening I know I'll go
forward
take the sales down
onto the booms neatly and tiredly
and by the time I wake up
this will have
all be over
and I went forward
I started to take the number one jib
down
but
the the boat was visibly
settling in the Seaway
you know and and Dougal suddenly
appeared
and said get the life raft over the side
and I thought this is for Real it was
just at that moment that I realized this
was for real this was really happening
and we were going to be eaten alive by
these killer whales and I was sure that
that was to be my fate
and I I picked the dingy up
put it over the side tied it onto the
starboard Rail and I put the put the
oars in and I got the life raft over
I threw the life raft into this into the
ocean pulled in the Rope hand over hand
hand over hand and you know you you get
to the end of the rope and you give it a
sharp tug like that
and I thought this is never going to
work
you know
that and to our relief and our great
relief
the life raft started to inflate and
unfold like that and we thought my God
thank God for that
and the next moment I was washed off the
deck a wave hit me in the legs washed me
off the deck and I was in the water
and I was thinking the whales are still
around
and I had heard some somewhere that you
don't feel
the bite you don't feel it
so I kept feeling to see if my legs were
still there
and
um they they we could hear the whales
but we couldn't see them at this time
and the raft was now blowing away
from the because the wind was quite
strong from the wreck the the lucette
was wallowing in the in the sea and
stationery but the the raft was blowing
away
and doodle now this is like a sequence
of events that sound like a disaster on
their own but when taken together
probably saved Our Lives okay Robin
the the student from Panama
had stepped you know when you're getting
a dinghy you step into the center of the
dinghy not until under the gun along the
edge of course he he stepped on the edge
and uh they've gone under the water and
it flooded with water and filled it's
filled with water so we couldn't use it
anyway oh no and Dougal tied that to the
raft
but that acted as a sea anchor to the
raft and kept the raft close to the
wreck side so we could all swim to the
dinghy it did to the raft sorry
and so therefore it saved us in a way
you know that seemingly disaster
saved us up the wrath from Blown Away In
The Wind because it would just have
blown away in seconds
and it makes you wonder about design
fold you know what I mean like sort of
you know it's not they're not as smart
as you think maybe they're okay for big
ships that can you can get off in an
ordered manner but it would not have
worked here but for that anyway the raft
was leaking and I was trying to stop the
leak and I kept on trying to put my
finger in the hole and things like that
but I didn't realize that um in actual
fact
the raft is made for inflating in the
Arctic and the Antarctic and he's got
enough CO2 in it so it's got an excess
of CO2 in the tropics because it's
hotter and the the the it was just
bleeding off the excess CO2 so I was the
last one to get into the raft and the
others were already there and we counted
each other we counted again that we were
all there my mum and dad thought I had
gone they thought they'd lost me so did
your mother and father Robin Williams a
hitchhiker yourself and the two twins
yeah all on the right sitting in the
raft looking very yellow because it's
got a canopy over it yeah it's made of
yellow material
and and my mom says
let's say the Lord's Prayer
and my dad said
I don't believe in God
and I'm not going to say the laws bro
and I said to Dougal I said dad you know
we might need God very soon
why don't you just say the Lord's Prayer
you don't have to mean it
and he said
Douglas if there was a god
don't you think he would know I didn't
mean it
and it wouldn't count anyway
and I just remember that moment because
I thought what a hard man
you know his life's on the line here and
he still won't give in
two minutes have gone past
that's all
but it seemed like a lifetime
and we looked at each other
and we looked out to see and the whales
had gone
and
we looked for a ship
that was never going to be found I mean
that we were in a very very
desolate part of the ocean
and my dad had always been our leader
we asked him if we were going to die
and do the looked at his family
and he thought
they don't deserve to be lied to at this
time
they deserve the truth
and somehow I've got to tell them
that we're all going to die
there's no hope we didn't get an SOS out
we had no food or water
I had managed to save two vital things
whilst I was out fixing the raft
and that was the generous sale
and my mother's sewing basket what's a
general sale it's a sale from the
lucette that was had been lying on the
deck and it just washed over the side
and it was part of the Flotsam if you
like in the water and I'd managed to get
that and get get minimum sewing basket
my mum's sewing basket was full of
Trinkets and things that were invaluable
to us like a pair of scissors a bit of
copper wire
bit of string these are invaluable to
Castaways you know although in a sewing
basket you look at you wouldn't even
notice we're there you know
and um Dougal
Was preparing us to tell us that this
this was a very serious thing that had
happened to us and that we're probably
not going to make it
and he started to
um sum up what had happened he says we
were 200 miles west of Cape Espinoza we
were hit by a killer whales that he said
it was sunk in less than two minutes or
two minutes or so
it's Dale it was Daylight thank God so
we could all get off the boat you know
citizen we've made it to the raft
and we've got we've got some water there
was 10 cans of water
maybe maybe 18 cans of water so several
cans of water
there's some rations enough for 10 days
that's where the 10 comes from he's
enough for 10 days
but we're in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean
where we're downwind
and down current
from the Galapagos Islands
we'd have to sail a hundred miles a day
just to stand still
if we were going to sail back to the
Galapagos Islands
so we can't go back to the Galapagos
of course
me 18 and a half years old who knows
everything
said to doogle dead
it's clear to me there's only one
solution
we know that it Reigns heavily in the
doldrums
and one of the things I came up with my
famous saying which is you can live for
30 days without food and three days
without water and 30 seconds without air
I don't know why I added that on but it
just seemed to rhyme
which water that we need
without water we're going to die and it
rains in the doldrums
why don't we sail to the doldrums
you know we've got the raft we've got
the dinghy
that that'll keep us afloat as long as
we can get water
we should be able to make it 30 days we
should be able to get to land in 30 days
can you explain what the doldrums are
the the trade winds blow
all year round varying strengths
seasonally
and they're the wins that they go right
around the world
and that each side of the Equator
so the trade winds blow into the equator
from the South and from the north
but because the Earth spins so if you
can imagine the the air is trying to
fill that Collide here and the Earth's
turning that it turns the wind that way
so you get the let me get it right the
southwesterly trade winds in the South
and the northeasterly trade winds in the
north of the equator and of course the
the doldrums is like the meteorological
equator it just moves up and down as the
trade winds move and so the two heirs
meet and go up
and it creates huge thunderstorms
massive like you'd never believe that
this the clouds go right up the
stratosphere and it rains heavily so we
should go there collect rain collect
water and then Douglas suddenly found
that whilst he was sort of explaining to
us why we were going to die
the conversation sort of switched to how
we might survive okay a sort of
assessment of what we had not what we
didn't have when we got enough water
strike out we had the oars
strikeout for the American Coast wow so
suddenly we had a plan
and without a plan you can't survive you
have to have a plan
and uh so Dougal found himself
explaining to us how we might survive
rather than how we might die
and he said this was a turning moment
for him
he realized that and and we looked up
you know the flame fish they're flying
fish out in the tropics let's fish with
very little big fins that to help them
fly so when a predator comes they jump
out of the sea and they fly for about
100 foot and then they they've got away
basically but the frigate birds fly in
the sky above and when they see one of
these uh flying fish jump out of the sea
they swoop down and just swoop it up and
eat it
snap his ass there and this happened in
front of us me and Dougal were
discussing this plan and uh a frigate
bird came down and just snapped up this
frying fish
as if mocking is
you know like look what I can do you
know you useless human beings you've got
no chance
and I said to my dad I said they've got
millions of years on us
and Google said yes Douglas
but we have brains
and with brains we can make tools and
with tools we can survive
well survives hard work survival is hard
work very hard work
first of all we had the raft and the
dinghy together we tied them together
with the wire from that generous aisle
that I'd saved right we
um we made uh we were visited during the
night by flying fish jump into the boat
we uh a Dorado a big dolphin sports
sport fish jumped into the dinghy one
night wow and we got that and killed it
you know raw just ate oh yeah yeah so
what you do you didn't have knives so
how would you no just tore it wow yeah
I'll tell you what human man mankind
just under the surface of civilization
is
thousands of years
of skills that we've forgotten
you don't need them living in London do
you but you don't know you've got them
till you end up in a situation like that
and suddenly you know what we caught
Turtles
I caught the very first turtle
it came along I had a a a a a a piece of
an all
and I hit it on top of the head
and his eyes filled up with blood
and he swam away
and I remember saying to Madonna said
Dad
you know
we've got to hunt not catch these these
animals don't want to give their lives
away they'll fight to the very end we
have got to catch and hunt them
and kill them
if we're going to
eat them
and we agreed that we had to be a lot
smarter the next one came along
and I thought well I'll lift it out of
the water
it won't be able to swim away then so I
lifted it straight out the water and
then I didn't realize it got razor sharp
those flippers they've got on the rear
of them they are bone and razor sharp
wow and now suddenly it's chopping my
hands like this you know and I threw it
into the raft which was the last place I
should have thrown it just now it's
flapping around inside the inflatable
raft and doodles go like this and
they're all jumped up on the thought you
know and Google picks this Turtle up and
throws it out through the front and so
the turtle's gone and we're back to
square one again you know we weren't
being very smart about this you know the
third Turtle came along and there was a
a a like a safety line with a Coit on
the end of it for throwing out to people
who were in the vicinity of the left so
you could pull them in
and I tied it up in that
and then so it couldn't move its
flippers and it couldn't get away and
Google went around to the dinghy which
was Towing us and I passed him the the
end of the rope and he pulled the turtle
around and we pulled the turtle on board
and we had a knife a kitchen knife I
don't know how it had found its way into
the bottom of the dinghy but it was
there
and doodle Cut Throat of the turtle
and bright red blood
spurted him
and I'd read a fiction story by Aleister
McLean called southbound Java head where
these people had survived on a Lifeboat
and they drank Turtle blood and I said
Dad I think you can drink Turtle blood I
mean it was a it's a novel right I said
give it a try
and he he he he drank some turtle blood
and realized that it was not salty
and that you could drink that and
perhaps live off it so we we we we sort
of thought that's a
a source of food very protein rich
and um
the turtles had red meat like steak
we thought we can dry this meat and
store it and
and
so Turtles became our Mainstay and were
they just around in we realized later
that mating it was a mating Instinct
that brought them to us so what happens
they must meet up in the deep sea and
mate and then in fact we witnessed this
and then that's it they're gone so if we
had two turtles in the vicinity say a
male and us and then a female came along
they would couple and go right so we we
realized we had to catch the males and
the females but the very first one we
caught was a female and in it was eggs
egg yolks hundreds of them like grapes
like Bunches of grapes how did you know
which bits you could eat or were you so
hungry you've got Instinct right you've
got Instinct we knew that the liver of
the turtle was poisonous how did you
read that never read it okay you just
looked at it you knew you couldn't eat
it right whereas the liver of the shark
you could eat it
and you get home and you find out that
the the liver of the turtle's poisonous
and the deliver of the shark is healthy
you know but you've got this innate
ability and you know you touch it in a
situation like this and I've read other
great survival stories where the people
have had the same experience a
realization comes to them what you can
and can't do I suppose it's a bit like
being in a in a forest and seeing red
berries and you get this sense of the
red berries are dangerous somewhere
inside soft red berries no don't eat
that you know you've got there's an
alarm ringing you know and we had a few
lemons and we had a few we had lemon
water
my mom had put a bag of lemons I see and
a bag of onions would you believe into
the uh a dinghy at the moment of the
Shipwreck but how so the way you're
describing it is amazing and it sounds
like a kind of like Adventure but was
there still a sense of impending doom
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely and the
younger kids the twins I think they were
immune to that too young I think they
were too young and they thought well I
don't know why we're doing this but if
my mum and dad are doing it then we'd
better be doing it and they were 12 or
13. yeah yeah maybe Sandy thought
a little bit that it was perhaps a
little bit unusual to be doing this sort
of thing you know but nobody was
screaming we're gonna die we're gonna no
no it was all let's just do that we made
a deal we made a deal to each other in
those early that first day
that no matter what happened we wouldn't
eat each other
and that we would die wow you said that
out loud yeah
because what what's it called the custom
of the sea is that oh yeah the customer
can you tell us about that well I mean
the customer of the city is outlawed now
yes but there is a book called the
customer the sea a very good read about
the very last case of cannibalism at Sea
where it was accepted up until that
ruling which is about 1870 something
like that until maybe 1800s mid-1800s
where you drew straws
to see who would be eaten the one that
Drew the shorts draw was the person that
would be eating and it was accepted as
the customer of the sea so that the
others could live so the others could
live and um they um they they
in Big Ships the the crew were even in
groups passengers first female
passengers before male passengers
then
semen
Sailors then ships officers
apprentices Cadets first chief officer
last Captain took no part in it
that was the customer of the sea and you
know
we thought about the customer the sea
and we decided because Robin of course
was not a family member
and we assured him that we would die
together
um do you think he was in this together
yeah I think he was very he thought you
might eat him he thought we might hit
him
and he was very gratified to hear us say
that we said no you are one of us you're
one of our family
and we will treat you like that
and we will die together if that's what
is going to happen
you know so we'd made that promise to
each other as well and you know these
are bizarre conversations aren't they
you know when when things like that
happen you have to discuss those things
so you know where you stand
Google was going to tell us we were all
going to die but he ended up telling us
we're all going to live we were
discussing how we were going to live
Robin thought we were going to eat him
secretly and we assured him that we were
not going to do that and we were sincere
we were sincere that if this is it this
is it and uh and what was the
temperature like hot very hot it's
Tropics so 37 degrees that's sort of all
the time but at night time it was it was
but it was still warm but it was cooler
but in those thunderstorms in the
doldrums it was Bloody freezing right
and we were shivering like we were so
you made it to the doldrums we made it
to the doldrums and how many days were
you out here when you got 10 days so 10
days and did it did it feel like 10 days
or did it feel like a year it felt like
a year it felt like all our lives that
did it was it was uh you know I'm
describing these things but they were
hard work a lot of innovation a lot of
hard work the raft was leaking so we
were up to our chests and water oh god
really we we we uh we couldn't sleep
because of that so we had a thought a
central thought
which was dry and you we could take an
hour turns an hour on that thwart then
you had to get back into the water again
so we rotated around so you just sleep
for an hour come back to sleep for an
hour and then get back in the water and
I always remember my mum God bless her
saying to me one day she said Douglas
you can take my turn on the thought
you know
and of course you take that you you take
it selflessly don't you you take it
and of course now I reflect on that
because of my mum
stays in the water and was cold yeah
that water rubs your body of heat and
they uh we knew the raft was killing us
staying in the raft was killing us it
developed leaks
and for children I just keep thinking of
the twins those young children like well
you you know you talk of the Twins and
you you talk of survival
but uh Dougal put it in his book and I
repeated it in my book
um that uh the twins kept us honest
we had a reason to survive it was to
save their lives
you know my mum and dad were full in
their late 40s they've kind of had their
lives you could say I'm not being
facetious I'm just saying they'd lived a
life
I was a young man I'd just become a man
I didn't want to lose my life
and Robin too you know he was a bit
older than me he was on a trip around
the world he didn't want to lose his
life and the twins hadn't even started
their lives
but my my dad said I'll get these boys
on a steamer home if it's the last thing
I ever do
he'd made us that promise way back on
that first day
and uh you know that gave us a reason to
keep going and maybe without that reason
to keep going I tell you what it would
have been so easy to just lie down and
die because it was so difficult to
survive bailing blowing up my mouth that
raft blowing it up my mouth eventually
on the 17th day the raft sank
and we had to all get into the dinghy
itself so now whilst it was dry in the
dinghy
if that dinghy flooded that was it we
would we were doomed so the dinghy was
the last last I think he was the last
Last Resort it's nine foot long three
foot wide but it goes down to a point at
the bow at the front wow so this and
three people lived in that space
and you know you've got to be wearing
this dinghy had three worlds three
entire worlds going on in the stinky the
forward end where my dad and the twins
were
uh where they overlapped each other
that Stern where me and Robin uh we
could you know we could lie with our
feet up like that but we could lie down
with our feet and our head on there uh
after thought
and then the the thought the central
thought where the watch keeper sat and
we rotated the the so the watch keeper
was always looking out uh hopefully for
a rescue ship that was not to be found
you know so what would you say was the
lowest moment the lowest lowest moment
was when we lost the water that we'd
been so carefully preserving
and you know Robin was not a sailor God
bless him and uh he he was not to blame
for what happened but we did entrust him
to tie the water bowl the water bag out
of the way while we kill this turtle
and he just didn't type properly
properly secured I mean he wasn't to
know that the turtle's flipper was to
catch underneath the bag and it just
flipped it out like this and suddenly
all the water was in the bottom of the
thingy
and we all knew immediately what that
meant
we had no water
you know turtle's Revenge yeah
absolutely and uh that they we were
became very despondent
and I remember saying to my dad look you
know Dan I can't go on
I I've had enough basically and I'm
ready to go
and my dad was a very hard man
very tough
and um
he said to me Douglas do not let your
bright light go out
so we need you to survive
so the rest of us can survive
and I said to him dad you can't even let
me die in peace you know we were deadly
serious now because we were we'd lost a
lot of weight we you know you see that
this can of water here
that would last a week
wow that's how I'm describing it but to
give it some context
we caught Turtles we had a little square
of meat three times a day that was our
food we were very very hungry but you
get used to hunger you after a couple of
days you you don't feel it the same way
as you do in the first two days
and the water which just sips just sips
and it was voluntary sips and not
everybody took us up when they should
have taken the Sip
especially my mum
and my dad was watching her and he made
her sip
you know she said the twins need it more
than me
and Dougal said no without you the twins
will not survive you have to drink water
you know and um there was a lot of
self-sacrifice
um amongst us maybe that wouldn't have
been the case had we not been a family
you know and um I'm just going to say
for audio listeners that um
Douglas held up a can of water that was
it's a very small can 300 milliliters
just for people who need a bit of
context for how long that would have
lasted yeah and when we were when we
lost the water we went five days with no
water
and that was when I said that to my dad
about I'd had enough and then you know
it rained in fact it rained away from us
and we thought this is just too much you
know it's raining over there if we were
over there we'd get that water and then
suddenly the heavens opened and it
rained on us you know and we collected
this water and it's you know water is
god-given without it you can't live and
we've filled our bag up and we were you
know we were back on for our trip we
were we would start rowing that night
for the American Coast
and uh so that was the worst moment but
the most terrifying moment was in the
doldrums when we got caught in a
thunderstorm and lightning was hitting
the water around us no and you could
smell that accurate smell of electricity
in the air just literally yeah it goes
straight down not a not a lightning like
a zigzag line like a fork of lightning
these are straight bolts of lightning
coming straight out of the base of the
cloud into the sea and as I remember
saying to my dad this is hell this is
what hell is like and he said yes it is
and I said you know we're going to get
hit by a lightning and we're going to
all get fried to death and every nobody
actually know how we died you know and
he said it could happen we agreed it
could happen
but the lightning was also a friend
because
I remember one night
when we were trying to uh it was very
bad weather
and we were trying to keep the bow onto
the waves to prevent the water from
swamping the dinghy
and I remember Dougal reaching the end
of his tether and uh
he was on the verge of giving up he
couldn't keep the boat it was a bow onto
these waves it was dark
and uh
a bolt of light you know sort of a glow
of lightning Shone through the base of
the cloud
and
my mum was looking at Dougal and Dougal
was looking at my mum
and
my mum was reminding him of that promise
he'd made that he would get his own
esteemer home
and so Google had that same moment with
my mum where you know their eyes can say
a lot
and where he was remanded of his
obligation really
and Google did acknowledge that
obligation he was not going to give up
easily but he he
it was desperate you know the water was
swamp in the boat we were Robin was
bailing my mum was bailing and I was
scooping out with my hands like a cup to
get the water out because so much water
it was raining so heavily and uh that we
didn't like to curse the rain because we
needed it to live by but we uh but this
was too much you know it was just too
much it was we had no clothes on all our
clothes had vanished they just uh
everything everything we were naked wow
and the rain was pouring on us and we
were so cold so when you say vanished
you mean just uh eroded I'll tell you
what had happened we we took them off
but they did a road as well and they we
took them off because we were covered in
boils from head to FUD oh from seawater
boils
and something called immersion fat if
you get immersed in water for a long
period of time you the blood supply gets
cut off from your hands and feet
and you you break out in sea water boils
and we found that by having no clothes
on because the clothes were harboring
the salt yeah and so if we if we took
them off
that we're actually the boils went away
but the the the emission foot was still
there while we were in the raft but not
in the dinghy so we're in much better
shape in the dinghy but it was a much
more dangerous yeah place to be because
of it sang there was no way back whereas
the raft couldn't sink because it was
inflatable all you had to do was keep it
inflated and that but that was a job you
know it was too much for us without
without a proper pump to um inflate the
raft but you work out methods and we
worked out methods to determine which
direction we were going
and how far we've gone
and you know after 38 days we were
picked up
and we were only 25 miles out
in our latitude and a hundred miles out
in our longitude
and we'd we'd just we'd invented this um
uh Cafe
that we would open when we got home this
gave us an excuse to talk about food
when you're hungry believe you me you
can talk about a pork chop for an hour
okay and how you're going to eat it when
you get home and what sources you're
going to put with it I mean that sounds
like adding to the torch and you go
church tell me about that sauce again
you know and what which what kind of
pork chop are we talking about here are
we talking about a line job or are we
talking about a pork chop with a long
you know the long rib bone the detail
that we went into
because we were so hungry and we could
visualize this food in our heads which
it was non-stop anyway we we decided
we'd open this Cafe and we had a menu
and we'd discuss things that might be on
the menu
and we were discussing that very
important subject this afternoon it was
cloudy
uh with replenished our water supply
after that after we'd lost it
and we were talking about how far off
land we may be
we thought maybe we're only 10 days off
land
could that really be true
it turned out we were six days of land
when we got picked up
I went and it was going to be that
afternoon but we didn't know it then
and uh
the uh
um
we were we were discussing this
a wine license
because I mean we discussed just about
everything else and this is kind of
fantasy isn't it so
and Google looked up and he said there's
a ship over there
and then returned to the conversation
about the wine line
and I said to him dad you said this ship
she's a ship a bloody hell is a
ship it's like almost we'd forgotten
that we were looking for a ship because
we were so focused on getting to land
and that was our whole sort of reason
deter so to speak you know we were
and suddenly the agency
um descended on us
we took the sale down and Dougal stood
on the throat something you must never
do but we we balance him
and he fired he held up one parachute
flare he struck thank God
and uh when then lasted him a minute or
two and went out well one flare left
until took the second flare it just sort
of it was a bit different but then it
struck and it was a red glowing red and
he held it up like this and it burnt and
burnt and burnt and then it was burning
his hands the the flux was dropping down
and burning his hand hands and he threw
it away like that
and that that Arc was the bit the
Japanese saw
they saw the ark a red a red ark
he described it the Helmsman described
as
and we knew that was our last Fleur so
if they didn't see that this was going
to sell right pastors again
and she altered course
10 degrees
was it was it just
rolling in a Seaway
was she just adjusting a course
then she altered course another 10
degrees
and then suddenly another turn and she
was pointing at us and we realized that
she was coming to pick us up
and Dougal said you know I think our
ordeal is over
and uh you know
well
I remember
the Japanese throwing a rope over to us
a dirty oily rope
and uh I grabbed it
and I looked at that rope and thought
this is this is our link back to
civilization
this I would normally not
hold such a rope you know what I mean
I'd kick it out of the way but here I
clung onto it for dear life because I
knew what it meant
and suddenly we were on the deck of of
the tokamaru
and we looked back and Google said will
you save the dinghy please and you know
the Instinct that the desire to save the
thing was to save the food in the dinghy
because we were so focused on food and
water we didn't want to throw our food
away
and the captain said we have food we've
got food on the ship and we were going
like sort of yeah you might not have
food you know it's a maybe you're lying
to us you know we've definitely got food
on that dinghy anyway they begrudgingly
hold it on board wow thank God because
that dinghy is now in the National
Maritime Museum in Falmouth
and you can go and look at it and if you
do go there and look at it
you will not believe how small it is how
six people could have fitted in that
dinghy it is astonishingly small
and there's a message on the on the
forward thwart a message to my sister
who had left us in Nassau
explained to her what had happened
so we were back on the deck of the
tokamaru
and we were looking back out onto the
sea we were safe now we were going to
Panama City
but we missed that and this is the irony
of it we were masters of our
fate
we had survived 38 days on that raft and
the dinghy and the raft combination we'd
caught Turtles we'd caught Dorado we'd
caught a shark even
we had caught rain water
so we were innovated we innovated and we
survived and we looked back at the Sea
of the Pacific and we missed it because
our Our Lives had value every day
verified every day because we were still
alive that was a simple measure and we
never thought
that we would survive another night
as we contemplated the darkness the sun
went down the night time was more
dangerous than the daytime
and we wondered if we'd ever see the sun
rise again
Douglas it's an absolutely amazing story
and you tell it incredibly and it's just
fascinating I can hear there's like a
pin drop in this room I can hear
everyone's absolutely wrapped in it but
we we've unfortunately run out of time
um the thing that I do want to say to
you is thank you so much for coming here
and talking to us about it it's an
amazing story of Hope and you know the
sort of indomitable will of pushing
forwards on diversity
um thank you so much for your time yeah
thank you and it's a pleasure to share
it there are times I've had chills on my
back and how the hell did that happen
how did I just walk away from that
somebody your distance from me
trying to blow my head off a mist
with Six Bullets has that happened yeah
God and I'm like how the is that
I'm gonna do this day I still don't know